ladies and gentlemen know this I would
like to bring you to the broken
simulation earth 2020 where the words
you speak literally the definitions can
alter the course of a virus let me
explain something to all the views are
people watching listen we have recently
learned that if you go out into the
streets with thousands of people linking
arms and you say these words no lockdown
all of a sudden the virus erupts from
the streets sprang out of sewer pipes
and it's hitting everybody in there
falling over screeching and gasping for
air but but there's one cure you need
only do literally the exact same thing
go out with thousands of people link
arms and say black lives matter and then
the virus dissipates and squeals in
horror and you dance and cheer and the
Sun comes out and the world has become a
better place you may experts say you
need experts they may think I'm joking
I'm not you were joking when you first
told me I'm gonna be honest yeah the
first thing that I'd like to show you is
this story from The Guardian oh hello
now this is just one of many stories I
decided to pull pull up US lockdown
protests may have spread virus widely
cellphone data suggests devices
associate with protests traveled up to
hundreds of miles to rallies where few
precautions were taken
now how many stories did we see just
like this in fact there were many saying
that the lockdown protesters are killing
grandma for instance
yeah well it's okay because now we've
learned that black lives matter protests
meaning quite literally the subject
matter may have slowed the overall
spread of coronavirus in Denver and
other cities a new study finds there it
is everybody quite literally the subject
matter of your protest will alter the
course of a virus we've done it we've
found it magic words it's it's true it's
magic
I always knew I always knew the human
race had had such potential who would
have thought while we've looked for the
ancient texts of spells that wit that
would grant us power of our physical
reality you needed you needed only to
have two different protests and start
saying different things until you
finally figured out soon enough we
realized
your political ideology can influence
whether or not a played will kill you
isn't that cool Wow Tim sent me that and
I said a miraculous it's it's it's it's
it's pure magic do you remember that
study that was going around about
writing the the words on water on the
side of a water cup yep hate love yep
whatever and they were like look at look
at the water crystals how they change
yeah and it's like it was actually not
really proven I was like well just I
want to actually look into it and there
was no actual bill your emotional energy
into water just like no this is fake
news look at this article it's very
obvious what they're doing the whole
thing's been political there is there
are people who are very stupid
unfortunately who think this will work
and unfortunately are correct when it
pertains as a pertain some people while
the protests brought thousands of people
together they likely caused many more to
stay home on a research team including a
University of Colorado Denver professor
concluded hold on wait so so here's the
logic the logic is this the logic is
that as thousands of people who normally
would be locked down decided to go
outside there's more people not out
there's more people inside I'm the math
is teaches it's what what does he teach
again he didn't do good in math I guess
I don't think yes there lie yes can't
run your business but we can burn your
business down yeah you can't go get a
haircut but we can go out and scream and
pull people's hair yes helping yeah
you're not allowed to run your business
but hey we're gonna gather by the tens
of thousands and chant and scream no and
then just when when when everyone's like
hey I kind of have a problem with you
saying I can't do this they go up what
like actually you're spreading kovat
more the science says that black lives
matter
saves live you a science denier I
imagine it's like this this study
actually has it came out wasn't research
and like well thought out it was a guy
who's like sitting in a room and he's
like the the protests actually slow the
virus by keeping people inside because
more people went outside no you know
maybe they were doing the the Joe Biden
tweet and they were like oh oh no what
that's legit that's posted yeah in
Colorado you know what the issue was it
was a hundred in Colorado you know what
they were doing what little puff and
pass yeah I think so though they call it
and here's the way we here's the meme as
the meme you go on you you type in
here's the deal and then you keep
pressing autofill predictive text and
then and then you fill up a tweet and
that's Joe Biden's speech so here's what
they did they were like we're gonna do a
study and his pet mashing it it's like
so they typed in black lives matter
protest may have and like slow down the
spread of kovat by keeping people inside
while they went outside and they're like
send have you stopped to think about the
logic of what you just said no they
don't people went outside and that means
whoa whoa whoa whoa sorry
logic and the left that those two L's
don't get along well yeah what does he
teach a professor in seriously well so
look to be fair the first two where I
pulled up says it may have no this was
saying actually so here's the deal what
they've basically said is we are now
able to go and protest for wherever we
want basically that's it unless you're
protesting the lockdown but there is
hold on I do have another fair
assessment as to what they're really
trying to say we need only change one
word in this article to make it actually
make sense shall I change the word for
you and reread that line please do pull
the story again there we go
let me read you the headline first black
lives matter protests may have slowed
overall spread of coronavirus in Denver
in other cities new study finds while
the protests brought thousands of people
together they likely caused many more to
stay home a research team including blah
blah now I'm going to change one word
okay and the whole thing will make sense
tracking okay black lives matter riots
may have slowed overall spread of
coronavirus while the while the riots
brought thousands of people together
they likely caused him anymore to stay
home I would say
a more accurate now that makes sense
yeah because now you actually do have
people who might normally go out for a
walk yep hiding in their homes as their
cities are ransacked and destroyed
that's a good point to terrorism so
using their language riots don't exist
right and my favorite is MSNBC where the
host is like now you know these protests
have been very peaceful while the
precinct the police department is on
fire and burning behind him it's all
peaceful
don't don't don't mind me there's a fire
behind things going on world Curtin
everything is fine that's what we get
man you know scary to me is when you
know I was arguing with it with what's
this dude I know from from back in my
neighborhood and it was about the the
Trump Russia bounty story do you know
the story oh yeah
that Putin you know offered a bounty to
Afghan militants to kill American
soldiers and it's the stupidest story
I've ever heard and it's just like it's
so bad the reason it's dumb and there's
a bunch of national security reporters
who brought this up right away which
made me laugh is they were like it being
the Afghan militants are low low cost
ill-equipped insurgents for the most
part who need no reason to kill American
soldiers none whatsoever they've been
doing it for four decades now right
offering them a bounty per soldier like
even is rather meaningless but more
importantly intelligence the
intelligence community is divided on it
apparently the NSA is saying we have no
evidence to support this Trump tonight
at Penn's denied it other administrated
ministration officials denied it the New
York Times has I guess like a single
unnamed source yep that's that's the
thing that keeps giving me I have all
the even people I know are like hitting
them all how can you explain this and I
was like you explained it to me then
because proof where's the proof I read
the article you just sent me there's no
proof they're like well the UK said it
and it's like okay well that's the UK
they reference the u.s. but there's no
actual proof that has anything to do
with it they're just alluding they're
like well see this makes sense and it's
like no it doesn't but I want I want
some actual tangible proof where's your
proof it's not even about whether you
support Trump or don't its that why am i
arguing with someone who's proven
nothing yes so it's like you come to me
with a story I say wow that might be
true can you prove it no you well then
have a nice day yeah and and not only
that they're like
I can't believe you can still support
Trump and I was like I just asked you
for some proof on this yeah calm down I
didn't even say Trump
I'm not even we're not even talking
about that right now I just want to know
if this if it is true I want to know so
I can report on it this is tell me that
it's true I want to find out if it's
true or not this is the big chance not
true let me let me I'm going to I'm
gonna take my humble nob from from you
know a good seven down to a zero right
now oh nice well I'm the founding member
of the fastest-growing news organization
in history and I regularly regularly
well I used to give guest lectures to
PhD journalism programs and I've guest
lectured several journalism programs and
spoken at many universities about
journalism and I've been flown out to
some of these very high-profile events
and been offered a job of some of the
biggest news organizations news
organizations in the world and even then
I will not pretend to know for a fact
what really happened so why is some dude
who drives trucks for a living telling
me I'm wrong because he saw a meme from
a reply guy claiming he should have been
selling American soldiers to Putin
exactly that's why he was so bad I
responded with I'm like I'm arguing with
this dude and I'm like hey here's what I
think and then their response is like
you're so dumb like obviously we know
this is true the New York Times said it
and I'm like one unnamed source does not
a confirmation make I mean it used to be
you needed three sources to confirm this
right they got one person saying hey we
did this and all of these denials and
then I finally ended with like you know
what bro I'm sick of this I'm not gonna
go to a doctor and say well I don't care
what you think about vaccines I'm gonna
go to them and say yeah you're the
doctor I'll take your word for it yeah
I'm at a doctor I didn't go to medical
school I'm not gonna pretend like I will
no it's like what Bill burr said to
Rogan when he was like yeah he's like
I'm not gonna do this I'm not gonna sit
here with no medical degree listen to
you sit there with no medical degree
talk about whether we should be wearing
masks there and I'm like excellent yeah
yes now that being said if I was to come
to you and say I know for a fact what
really happened then by all means
challenge me mm-hmm but if I go to you
and say as a journalist and political
commentator and cultural commentator I
have not seen har definitive proof and
to be honest the track record for these
stories is like a serious net net
negative yeah like the the intercept has
put out this very fun story I love the
top 20 stories on Russia gate that
failed so I'm sorry the birth
of proofing New York Times you can't
just say we talked to one person who
thinks it happened you need to prove it
exactly and then don't come and argue
with me that you know how the news
actually works when you've done no
research on this and I swear to god the
source was a reply guy was one of those
people who responds to Trump it makes
things up exactly like your source of
news is memes dude means it's occupied
Democrats okay well I'm gonna turn your
turn the hum bility back up yeah turn it
back to bility so humble humble by
humble bar 2:11 there was there's a
report that comes out every year called
it's a news WIPs you know engagement
tracker whatever okay the funny thing is
I think this is 2018 now so I need to
update my information on this one but
the number one source of engagements for
conservative news can you guess which
outlet conservatives flock to and large
like the biggest numbers I mean based on
what we talked about earlier Eyck
minutes I don't know you nailed it as a
fox
bingo you win the grand prize Fox what
do I win yeah a thousand points
a UFO spin you a postman so
conservatives according to this report
Fox News is the number one source of
information for conservatives okay now
do you know what the number one source
for news for Democrats for left-leaning
individuals was I have no idea it
occupied right address occupied
Democrats occupied Democrats is a
conspiracy theory meme page where they
just make fake fake memes so I wasn't
wrong you were very safe yeah well it's
worse than reddit Yeah right it's an
aggregator okay
but yeah it's occupy Democrats didn't
read the most engagement among the Lux
Wow so they're getting their information
from a picture of Trump going like and
then it says like Shrunk kills babies
and children and locks them in cages
yeah that's why when you try to talk to
logic and like actual oh well here
here's where I'm getting my information
this is what I know about it all what do
you know about it like that's all you
get like well if you don't know what I'm
know then you just don't know and then
they walk away I've gone insane yeah
it's like what is that where's that
logic like what happened to having a
conversation like I was just trying it I
was straight up trying to have a
conversation with who I thought was a
friend of mine earlier today on Facebook
it devolved into AI
no you anymore I can't believe you're
such a racist now and I'm like what are
you talking to like I had well like me
yeah I'm talking to me like what are you
talking about let me tell them that you
work for a minority-owned company
I should have should have led with that
missed opportunity you know next time I
love my favorite thing about the the
whiteness definition is what their
ultimate goal is actually to make
everyone white I'm not getting
interested so one of there's a few
arguments they use
no wonder they got rid of Aunt Jemima so
quick oh yeah no no they want so so here
they say they say white there's an that
this is a recent article that came out
that white isn't actually a real ethnic
descriptor okay because say back in you
know 1700s whatever Italians weren't
considered white right right and then in
the early nineteen hundred years ago it
wasn't like that well a hundred years
ago Irish people right weren't white or
whatever right and so they're like that
proves that whatever white is is just
the dominant group so now they're
arguing that Asians are invalid yes 100
cent that's why there's so that's their
justification for discriminating against
Asians and I'll tell you what man I had
one of the best conversations ever with
these lunatics I was in it was a Seattle
okay and I was at u-dub University
University of Washington in Seattle and
this guy was a weird weird guy was we
were arguing about something and then
all of a sudden I I think I said
something like you realize like the
white supremacist people you're talking
about right now are like Asian dudes
like mixed-race Asian dudes and then he
immediately jumped to the yeah well we
all know that Hitler you know the Nazis
and the Japanese were allies and I was
like okay they weren't well they were
the axis right so if they were allies we
would have they were ally with each
other not necessarily if they actually
worked together that wor might not have
happened the way it did and I say didn't
work together right they were doing
their own separate thing right and so my
point was like that's basically my point
I'm like what I was like you're arguing
that like that in in 1987 Oh a white
dude married a Chinese woman because of
World War two yeah well and he was like
bro is like I'm telling you
man these white supremacists love Asian
women and I'm like white supremacists
want to mix the race about dude and then
and then and then I turned nah I think I
got and I was like bro are you actually
arguing against race mixing like are you
a white supremacist and then he was like
no no no I'm like bro you're literally
pulling out like like some kind of weird
you know anti Asia I don't mean like
that and I'm like yeah you do I think
you do I think you just let the max mask
slip a little too much yeah I see what
you're really mad about this this is a
white guy I tell you what man these
people in Pacific Northwest's screaming
racial slurs you know I think you know I
have to question because we talked about
about this before like who really
benefits from their policies who
benefits from removing Aunt Jemima from
Aunt Jemima pancakes the family's angry
about it I know they are exactly they
they don't want it to happen I don't
either
I see Angela my mom like that's a sweet
that's a sweet looking lady yeah
literally sweet they're taking something
away they're taking away the legacy from
a black family you know how about look
at that that was it called DC black
tours was that the guy yeah that guy see
what a boss man he's the guy fending the
Lincoln statue and PETA and these young
people screaming at him and I'm like the
statues being defended by a an older
black man who's an another straight-up
really been through it all and he's he
talks and and and then he says like who
paid for the statue who paid for it and
they don't realize it was paid for I
freed my freed slaves no and what he
said what he said was what you need to
protest is that they they turned it
around
it's supposed to be facing the White
House I guess and it was like it was it
was change direction or something
I don't know that's true but he was
saying something like that and
apparently I watched a video from an
older black woman explaining the statue
okay she was saying something like it's
supposed to symbolize this person's
chains are being broken and they're
realizing what true freedom is and
they're grateful to Lincoln the great
Emancipator yeah and it was paid for by
the freed slaves so I actually I can
understand why people look at it and say
you know our freedom should not be
predicated upon though you know the
white Americans or whatever but it's
still history still it's still what
actually happened that led us here to
have them be free but their feelings
don't matter
feelings that's the point feeling I can
understand how they feel about it
but when you have the older crowd the
elders and the majority saying straight
up we we recognize and we appreciate and
we want this statue you don't get be the
one person with hurt feelings saying I
will burn it all to the ground exactly
and that's what and that's where we're
at man it's just people playing with the
strings of emotions of these young
people they're just control it's all
control that's all it is yeah you know
nasty people who have who have it's
insane people with insane objectives you
know and the funny thing is I love that
quote from John Lennon it was something
like you know they're insane people
running the country for for insane
reasons and I'm likely to be put away as
insane for saying it something like that
okay it's like it's still true to this
day yeah the the Democrats are literally
insane I'm sorry man feels like it yeah
here's how I feel right now about the
whole system I think Nancy Pelosi is not
necessarily insane oh I do me up I think
I think figuratively insane in that
she's willing to cede all of this
ideological territory to into truly
insane people yeah okay it would be like
you being the mayor you know Gotham City
being like well instead of fighting the
Joker let's just let him have it
let him have us go of it I guess yeah
see what happens yeah get tired
eventually well you know it's a it's the
young people and their ideas out crazy I
go at it Joker it's like these these
people have no goals they're just
running around bouncing off the walls
oh it just sounds like bad pairing but
here's what I think the Republicans are
nothing I think they're just I don't
even know what they are there's a small
handful of my can name that I think do
good things you know like I mentioned
Rand Paul for instance I think he's
really the best we got yeah I mentioned
him earlier because he's actually
putting bills out that would help fix
some of the problems they're out there
protesting and the Democrats are
stopping him it's like hmm what are the
what are the rest of the publicans do
what do they do as I said I'm still
learning about politics I I don't know
many Democrats I don't know many
Republicans I'm learning more and more
as we go and it's like it's really not
good it's not a good look on the
Democrats from what I'm learning Tucker
Carlson one of the reasons he has the
highest ratings ever he's calling out
the Republicans yeah he had this really
viral segment right now where he's got
this I think is a Republican senator
from Indiana okay who's in favor of
police reform and limiting qualified
immunity now and
like why are you saying that you know
what the cop did in Atlanta was it was a
tragedy what should he have done and
this Republican can't say anything and
he's like you are siding with these
people I'm saying and I'm not saying so
I'm seeing a lot of Trump supporters say
like the Republicans are siding with the
looters even a little bit yeah because
they're like okay okay we'll give you a
little bit of what you want just please
don't hurt us
that's it so you've got a little bit
they they realize that they can take
whatever they want then it's an
avalanche and the Republicans are
certainly you know near the top of the
slope as everything goes crashing down
and they're and the Democrats are at the
bottom just a free-falling it's bad
parenting it's them giving the the
crying baby all the attention because
the babies crying it's like sometimes
you have to let the baby finish crying
and and not pamper them not coddle them
no still it's already those likings
apparently spankings are bad they say so
I'm not gonna pretend I know how you
raise kids but I'll tell you what if you
if you know I what all of this far-left
stuff mm-hmm
it reminds me of I think it was a
feature on episode I love I love using
feature AMA for references yes yes yeah
I know this yes you do I could be wrong
about it but it's like it's a woman and
she's got her kid
maybe it's Simpsons and the kids like
mom I want you know this video game or
something and then she's like well I
don't know if she could shut up mom get
me the game it goes well okay and then
she buys it yeah and I'm like that's it
mom the mom is the Democrat and the kid
is the progressives and the kids are
like shut up Pelosi give me what I want
goes okay I'll just give you what you
want and then she liked hens the keys to
the castle just letting it all burn down
and we're sitting there like stop just
tell them to shut up mm-hmm yeah you
know I love you with them there's that
South Park episode where they were
they're giving the kids red illan and
adderall or whatever I think it's
Ritalin okay and then I think it's South
Park yeah what they're like explaining a
non-medicinal way to get kids to act
properly okay you know I'm talking about
this episode I think you reference this
before there's like a bunch of kids and
they're like bouncing around all crazy
man and there's like notice how the
children won't sit down and pay
attention now I'll apply the
non-medicinal effort and he whacks the
kid and the kid stops and he's like see
now the child is focused and paying
attention
let's try it on the next jobs and he
walks over and the kids bouncing and
then he slams table [ __ ] down and [ __ ]
and the kid freezes and he's like and
once again the treatment works I don't
know if that's necessarily good but
maybe it's because these these kids have
no one's strong to look up to
yeah like Oh alpha male man like
apparently right now Kellyanne Conway's
daughter is going viral because she's
ragging on her parents and Trump okay
and I'm like you know it's probably fine
kids rebel and all this stuff but what
about that youth at Michigan GOP guy
whose daughter was like going hard
against him saying don't vote for him
please fall and I'm like how have you
raised your kids this way and right
exactly
it's on you man you know what she's
right no when she said don't vote for
him she's right I won't that's a good
point
because if she if she is if she views
you that way if your daughter doesn't
believe in you and your dad well that's
not how he raised the his daughter it's
that he didn't raise his daughter that's
part of how look no matter what you do
you raise your kids okay if you raise
them poorly by neglecting them and
failing to teach them it's how you're
it's you it's what your choice is made
all right good point so the way I see it
is either he raised her poorly hmm and
she's disrespectful and disobedient and
has no respect you know okay fine then
why would I trust this guy to leave the
country or he did race her properly and
she's legitimately like a man there you
go yeah that's the kid you raised I'll
take their word for it yeah but you know
I guess the the crux of the conversation
has spoiled kids who think they deserve
everything you know romping around
smashing things and again to go back to
the Joker it reminds me of that The Dark
Knight when the Joker says he's like a
dog chasing a car you wouldn't know what
to do if you actually if you ever
actually caught if you ever actually
caught one right and so this is what
happens when these people go out Andrew
Cuomo said this he says you've won what
do you want and they were like
smash and I started just wrapping around
so Andrew Cuomo actually said to the
protesters he gave a public statement he
said you've won we agree now tell us
what you want and they couldn't write
marching around screaming justice and so
we want it's like what does that mean
you don't they don't know what it
matters because they're ignorant they
don't have any idea they have no clue
dude watching these videos from the
Chazz it's insane it's it's a war zone
that's it totally so according to one
witness
they said the chads2 any National Guard
fired three hundred rounds and saying at
a car and I don't believe that how many
times that would they have to reload to
fire three maybe like well sure from you
learning one gun but when you have six
or seven people or three guys okay three
guys but even if you even if you had six
firing 50 rounds I mean that would be it
you'd hear it the videos that's insane I
from the few videos that I did here
there's a lot of pops
yeah but 300 rounds does feel a little
exaggerated right but that's that's
again those are the videos that we've
seen you know do from you know actual
video evidence these are kids it is what
it is who are who are playing adult
versions of cops and robbers yeah riots
and revolutionaries i watch one of these
videos that went you know one of these
live streams you can see some of these
people like 18 19 years old dumb looks
on their faces it's like totally shocked
at a car is covered in blood yeah and
they're just like oh wow blood is real
that's real blood at least at least and
you hear this is my favorite quote it's
like a crime scene is that what they
said yeah Wow yes it is that's what
happens when you shoot somebody cry
you'll see you know it's really crazy
about the chances that I was watching
the live stream from these guys and guy
and he explained that there were several
shootings the other day and I'm like
whoa whoa whoa what how come we never
heard that mm-hmm because people think
it hit so he explained that there have
been multiple shootings where no one got
injured of course because of that no one
reports anything a gunshot goes off no
one says anything a gun shot goes off
somebody gets hit all of a sudden now
you've got a major international news so
he was like earlier today there was a
couple shots fired fortunately nobody
was hurt and then like you know a little
bit after that we heard some gunshots at
the park and I'm like you mean to tell
me that there were
three shootings that day yeah but it's
to get reported every time a gunshot
goes off it's crazy so people don't know
they only hear that we are only here by
the shooting course someone actually got
hit how many times happens has someone
been shot at probably all we know the
first shooting wasn't the actual first
shooting was the first thing that was
successful yeah gosh why not you hear
the dad of the victim is calling for the
National Guard to come and plow it all
down I kind of want them to can you
blame yeah the city needs to get a hold
of it and the mayor instead of actually
dealing with it is complaining about the
other Councilwoman because she's going
against her yeah and I don't blame her
seriously there a lot of people are
saying like yeah yeah get her get her
off the council and put her into the
mayor's seat just like oh yes good good
I know exactly this this woman this
councilman mm-hmm led a protest of the
mayor's house okay
I don't agree for don't agree with the
reasons but I'm glad the mayor's getting
protested yeah she is she is she is just
man the way described is like imagine if
your house like you get your dog barked
on your floor
like right when you're bout to go to
work and you're like oh man I don't have
time to clean this up so you hire a
cleaner right okay and they're like they
show up and you're gotta leave for work
can you clean this up so when I'm back
everything's clean look you got it you
come back the bar still there they're
like yo I thought I hired you
specifically to deal with this and
they're like managed this and they're
like oh you know we're we're gonna talk
about it and hopefully it dries and
clears up on its own you're like why did
I hire you if you can't do the job and
that's the mayor of Seattle oh man it's
better I bet to her when she was running
she's probably thinking how easy it's
gonna be lots of mayor's thought that
until this year
sit back you're gonna do the fray got to
live in the mayor's mansion good just
hand me a mansion yeah this is sweet
yeah yeah get access to city budgets for
planning how you want a plan doing what
you want to do yeah and then the riots
came and then she was like and now
there's like multiple shootings five
people I believe have been hit there
have been other shootings where no one
got hit fortunately and the city isn't
killed seriously yeah so earlier today
they tried clearing it out and then the
protesters just immediately put it back
up because they're not arresting them
yeah they're not dealing with the
problem
so what so what can we expect there
they're setting it up in in New York
City now yep they're expanding their New
York autonomous zone yeah now other like
DC and other cities have crushed these
autonomous zones just like it was
satisfying to watch the DC shut down the
congressman tables mm-hmm
get out here I was like I've been in
Portland which is super far laughs
that's true
the mayor came in and crushed the
autonomous zone mm-hmm god I couldn't
imagine being in Seattle you heard about
that billion-dollar firm 1.5 billion
dollar management firm is Linux moved to
Phoenix yeah I'm hearing other companies
are saying the same thing I don't blame
him there was another story I read where
they basically said that the economy is
being crippled and obviously with the
mismanagement by the government there's
just better opportunities and benefits
in other places you know so like I think
other companies are playing on
relocating to Texas and stuff like that
yep which can be bad for Texans if a
bunch of Seattle people move there you
know they bring their politics with them
but Seattle what's gonna become it's
gonna be Detroit Detroit I think oh yeah
yep you know the funny thing we've
already got Kovan mm-hmm now we've got
co vid wave number two of course as long
as you say black lives matter that the
virus goes away you have to worry about
it but what's gonna be left of cities at
all without autonomous zones
I don't know I'm over living this yeah I
lived in New York for most of my adult
life and I am so happy I don't live in a
city anymore I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna tell you one what our plan is I'm
gonna say it straight up do it work
we're getting a Space Station it's a
giant ring you may have seen it in the
movie Elysium and it spins to create an
artificial grab I'm kidding is doomed
yep bye guys and it's gonna be a big
bringing us guys will be podcasting that
is a pretty cool museum yeah but it was
so obvious we were I did know it's true
it was like the people on earth spoke
Spanish and the people in Elysium spoke
French hmm uh-huh
notice that I did say yeah we get it we
get it we get it thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon
have this podcast up for free on all
podcast platforms thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you